in this video we're going to talk even
some more about parallel resistors
parallel resistors
are resistors that are connected end to
end
and share the same nodes
here's r1 and r2 they share the same
nodes that one
and that one and that means they share
the same voltage
and we worked out a uh
an expression for
how to replace that with a single
resistor or parallel
and we found that
one over r parallel
is 1 over r1
plus
1 over r2
so in this video i'm going to actually
start working with this expression a
little bit more
and we'll just change it around a little
bit to an easier and easy way to
remember it and then we're going to do a
special case where r1 and r2 are the
same value and we're going to see what
happens
so right now i just want to do a little
bit of algebra on that expression 1 over
rp is the same as
1 over r1
plus
1 over
r2
what i want to end up with here is an
expression that on this side says rp
equals something and on this side i just
want one expression not not two
fractions so we're going to go about
that by combining these two fractions
first
so the least common denominator here l c
d
equals r1 times r2
and i'm going to convert both these to
convert this to that proper denominator
i have to multiply it by r2 over r2
so we'll do it
we'll do all the steps
we'll multiply it by r2
over r2
on this expression we have to multiply
it by r1 over r1
and this equals of course one over rp
continuing on
1 over rp
equals
r2
over
r1 r2
plus
r1
over
r2 and now i could combine them together
let's let's move up here
1 over rp
equals
we'll keep everything in numerical order
r
plus
r 2
over
r 1
r 2.
and
now i'm going to take the reciprocal of
both sides of the expression so i get an
expression in rp
rp
equals
and just flip over this expression
r1
r2
over r1
plus
r2
that
is a way you can remember how to combine
parallel resistors the parallel
equivalent resistor rp
is the product of the two resistors over
the sum so it's a product
over the sum
that's how i remember it
now this arithmetic this expression is
exactly the same as the original one
that we had
these are the same
and it's just a question of which one do
you
want to remember which one's easier to
remember and which one's easiest to
calculate
i like to remember this one here
let's do a quick example using it
move the screen up a little bit
let's leave that there so we can see it
let's say we have two parallel resistors
and we'll say the one the first one is
1000 ohms
and the second one is 4000 ohms
and the question is what is the parallel
combination of those things how can i
replace these with one resistor
so the same current flows
and we'll use this expression here so rp
equals a product which is one thousand
times four thousand
divided by
the sum
one thousand
plus four thousand
and that equals oh my goodness there's a
lot of zeros here four
and six zeros one two three
four five six
over
that's easy
five thousand
all right
and let's say let's take out
three zeros out of this one
let's knock off three zeros here
and three zeros here
and i have four thousand
divided by five
and that equals eight hundred ohms
so that is this
and that's how we use this expression
now just something to notice here notice
that uh our parallel the equivalent
parallel resistor is smaller
than both of these and that happens
every time that happens every time the
parallel resistance is smaller than the
smallest resistor so here it was 1000
it's going to be smaller than that
and that's a property of parallel
resistors because you have two current
paths
that allow current to go two different
ways
the effect of resistance is always
smaller than the smallest original path
because there's a way for current to go
around another way
so this is now the expression
for two parallel resistors and that's a
good one to remember
now i'm going to show you one special
case and we'll do this in
this color
what if
r1
equals r2
what is rp
and for this special case we use the
same expression we say
rp
we say rp is
the product
we'll just use r because r is this it's
the same value r times r
over r
plus r
and that's multiplied
and so that is r squared
over
2r
and one of these r's cancels so let's
cancel
let's cancel that r and that squared
and we end up with
r over 2.
so for the special case
if
r1
equals r2
then
rp
equals
r over 2.
it's just half
and that should make sense if that that
if we do something like this if we draw
two resistors in parallel
like this
and we say this is 300 ohms
and this is 300 ohms
that means the effective
the effective parallel resistor
ohms
and that's got a very pleasing symmetry
to it because these resistors are the
same they have the same voltage they're
going to have the same current
basically twice as much current is going
to flow in this circuit as would flow
if there was just one of these guys so
that's where the divide by two comes
from so for two resistors in parallel if
the resistors are the same value
the effective parallel resistance
is just half